why is everything gay
i don't know you're probably listen this
there's probably a large percentage of
your
of your viewers that are gay i'm setting
them right that's fine i'm going to get
canceled my podcast i'm going to get
shadow banned because i said the words
what is shadow bit is that a real thing
yeah i mean i got shadow bands last week
on episode youtube what does that mean
it means they take your [ __ ] off search
if you search for it it doesn't
propagate at all in search
whoa yeah basically nobody sees it
anywhere
just saying shadow band probably just
got you shadow rant mm-hmm
well they're already okay so this
doesn't do well it's not my fault
yeah it sucks it happened to me uh well
i forget what episode what was it on i
did an episode a week ago
what was it all about the guy no it was
the guy it was tom o'neill he wrote a
book about charles manson he spent
20 years investigating the manson
murders and basically found all these
holes in these why would that be shadow
by him
so the title i went to i think i went a
little too crazy with the title
redo the title i well i didn't have to i
tweeted at youtube
and i asked i asked youtube i said hey
what's the deal
my why is this episode not appearing
anywhere on search you can search for
the literal exact title of the episode
and it doesn't appear on search like
it's impossible to find it unless you
actually go to the channel
you know go under videos you'll see it
there and they said oh it probably got
flagged in our system
which means it's invisible on search
and then the next morning it was back up
it was visible
so it's a thing they do i mean basically
it's a real thing it's a real thing yeah
so
the title of the video was something
like uh the cia's
secret program to
brainwash people with or how the cia
brainwashed
charles manson with lsd basically
something like that and i guess that
triggered their system too much they
took it off search
but that's crazy isn't it it's [ __ ]
crazy that they they do that
they they have something that will
literally take your [ __ ] and make it
invisible to people
that's not crazy to me no no why
why wouldn't they do that they own the
[ __ ] platform do whatever they want
okay they have they have people they've
got to protect and here's the problem
yeah well the cia yeah yeah probably you
think the cia doesn't use
youtube's information for [ __ ] intel
and stuff i'm sure they're
somebody i think they 100 can use
youtube's information but that goes
against
[ __ ] whatever amendment the free
speech eventually that's what i was just
gonna say is like a lot of people would
argue
hey well it's a private company they can
do whatever they want but when you
become so
large that you kind of become a a part
of like the social fabric
then you you get to that point where you
go okay well wait a minute you're you're
a monopoly now
so people don't really have an
alternative
that's as widely used i mean this is a
massive massive platform
like nobody else is there you can say oh
yeah you could use reddit
you can use no you can't nothing's like
youtube it's massive
so at that point you kind of have to
start abiding by
like the current institution you know
well it's like a new concept
so you're saying what they're saying is
no it's ours we own it no no no
you know you have to start abiding by
you know like the constitution at that
point
there comes a point where you're so
large that you're like a town square
right you're a monopoly you can't
because now you can actually start
swaying things you can start censoring
is that real
do you have to do that i mean you do i i
think you get to that point it's kind of
like uh um
well there's no law saying that no
they're there yeah that's what i mean
they are monopoly
i mean yes and yes and no look at uh
look at microsoft like back in the in
the 80s
when microsoft came out they started
saying um
microsoft started saying hey listen oh
you're a small
you're a small um you're a small
software
store that sells software great yeah we
want to sell your windows okay here
here's our windows
so you can sell our windows but we also
need a percentage of everything else
your store is selling
what yeah so you're so here's the
problem is that they were
people they were getting they were doing
that well that
that becomes illegal because you become
basically you're almost it's almost like
racketeering
if they their whole thing was well they
don't have to sell our product yeah but
if they don't they go
under right because it's the main
product that's being sold out there
everywhere so you're basically saying
you can go under or you can give me a
portion of your business
and people are doing it while they
launch this massive investigation that's
back when they were talking about
breaking up microsoft
like this thing is too big we're going
to have to break it apart
and and you know they fought it and they
obviously they didn't but then they
stopped doing that also they said okay
we'll stop this practice and this
practice and this practice
it's really scary it's really scary
especially if you're on your own you're
independent somebody who's creating your
own stuff and this is how you
pay your bills that's how you make a
living off of making these videos and
posting [ __ ] on youtube
right because you have to literally
you're constantly worried about these
boundaries that you have to stay within
like there's guys there's youtube
channels with guys like specifically
talk about guns and firearms and like
the second amendment and all this stuff
and these guys
they could just take it away well these
guys have tons of followers tons of
subscribers
but they're demonetized so youtube can
choose the type of content
to make they'll make it unprofitable
like they can literally choose to make
certain topics
unprofitable for people to talk about
which takes away their incentive to talk
about these sort of things right
on their platform which is crazy which
influences the culture of
everything yeah i absolutely agree with
that i mean look look when
that's the spider-man quote with great
power
comes great responsibility um do you
remember that spider oh yeah okay
so i think that's true you know i think
that's true mm-hmm
you know i mean imagine being [ __ ]
trump bro [ __ ] kicked off twitter
kicked off youtube facebook everything
yeah what else are we talking about wait
oh wait uh um
no it's it's [ __ ] i mean it's it's
we're not gonna solve it it's [ __ ]
incredible it's incredibly
scary bro yeah yeah
you have to stay very kind of vanilla
and you can't
and the other thing is is those people
they're not gonna talk to you like
they're not gonna you think that you can
just send them an email or
make a phone call and say hey can we
work on this can can we work something
out let's
let's you know i'll promise to behave
from now on and follow your rules no
they don't you're you're done
they could just suspend you for whatever
the [ __ ] they please if they don't like
what you're talking about or if they
think that
it could be even by accident that you
get flagged for something
or like a troll flags your video for
something that they don't like
yeah boziac got a video taken down when
are demonetized or was it taken down
or if you because in the process of it
he talked about how he got
a like an upper respiratory infection
from wearing masks
and he went to the doctor and the doctor
was like well how
often how many masks do you have he's
like i don't know one or two he's like
do you ever how often do you wash him
he's like i don't know
barely ever he's like how long have you
worn that was like i've worn this one
for like a week he's like
they were like that's a problem we're
getting more and more of these
infections so during the
conversation talking about the infection
he's like i'm sick of these masks
i'm sick boom what happened to it
the video yeah i don't know if it got oh
yeah it got taken down they took it
was it it was a strike whatever it was a
strike they took a
strike on his channel for saying that
he's sick of the masks
yeah yeah it was a strike it wasn't like
a copyright strike
right it was some other kind of strike
and i said did you fight it did you
because if they watch the videos like no
man i was i don't know what
to do like what am i supposed to do he's
like it doesn't matter it was a five
minute video
you know he's like i don't care it's
fine but yeah it was
just because he happened in the course
of it just said this and he was really
only saying
that he was just you know up he's tired
frustrated he's just frustrated he's not
saying
he's not telling people no right but
they struck it immediately
yeah it's crazy they do that to a lot of
people they do it to legitimate doctors
that go on youtube and talk about
their studies on the chronovirus or they
talk about their patients who have had
covid and what they think the science or
what their opinion is or what their
research says about the science or
whatever
and if it goes against like an official
the official narrative
youtube it's done so there's no
there's no area for conversation about
it there's no area there's no room for
nuance in anything as long as
if it's against the official narrative
youtube will strike you
and demonetize you and ruin your ability
to profit off of
whatever you're talking about or even
ban you from youtube a little correction
it's just a little correction it's like
having a shock collar on
yeah that's crazy this is a little don't
go out of the yard
mm-hmm yeah exactly don't go out
you want to get zapped up